yeah yeah and what you do is you take it
like it's a piece of toilet paper that
has [__] on it and just like a bad
experience you get [__] over it you
don't want to hold on to it because it's
got [__] on it and it's terrible and you
put it in the toilet when you're done
with it and guess what you do you flush
it and it goes bye
it goes bye bye
poopy experience
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
voice exercises are coming well don't
say that I didn't uh
uh speaking of Harry call
it's cool that Gene Hackman isn't dead
oh dude what's cooler is on how much
noise Our Guest is making with this and
we just started we literally just
started we decided to be like Mr Bean
and he's wearing a tin foil and what
does the Hat say
I [__] up oh it says hat says quiet
hey Matt stop swearing if you could only
Fargo thing
realize who's had to look at his own
Fargo hat
um oh like you've never done it dude
sang why the bad word before the time I
know but then when I do it I go oops and
don't do it again you did it twice so I
didn't feel proper like guilt you got to
feel shame and like really really get
down on yourself okay okay remove that
I didn't do this dude yes you this was
here I didn't do this yes you did I sat
down and that was there I sat down it
was here no no no no no no no no no no
no it was on top of your thing that you
didn't use oh okay fair enough fair
enough you know what I'm saying it's not
my fault can't believe you actually
granted me that I was right well because
you were I don't I don't like lies you
know
um so wait uh he has hat that says quiet
but let's actually bypass that yeah
Chris I know where you want to go with
this yeah go ahead that oh he texted us
he goes damn Gene Hackman huh
did he die and he goes yup he says yup
and then five minutes later oh never
mind he didn't die so maybe we could
learn start that
start the clock start the clock so it's
like and then we were like what happened
and he was like my friend told me he
died no you said well we said what
happened he said he died
simple as that no I said he'd oh he died
yeah he said yeah yeah then he said 10
minutes five minutes later uh he didn't
die well only because I I was like I
Googled it and there's Gene Hackman and
it's like the literally all the
headlines were like Gene Hackman looking
alive and well when he's like 93 and he
looks doesn't even look like Gene
Hackman he looks like a character in
Beetlejuice you know and they're like he
looks great yeah yeah yeah so why did
you say that he died so what we want to
know is why you said that he died when
he absolutely didn't die what is it
about when people die people want to
tell everybody though I don't know
that's pretty pretty morbid huh I don't
they might be the first to tell you go
out of my way to not do that sir
mix-a-lock died because I don't know the
person and it doesn't really matter
because everyone dies all the time
people die everyone's always dying a
little bit more every day or they're
literally dead you know what I'm saying
Sir Mix A Lot died people will Mix A Lot
died so I'm gonna text you yesterday oh
absolutely yeah he was alive and well
and then he just goes giddy up you turn
oh and died
what's up death what's up wow
um what's up heart attack what's up
did we ever learn no why did you say
Gene Hackman died because my friend
texted me that Gene hack why did why did
that friends say that no no I'm gonna
before we even get into that why did the
friend say it okay because they saw go
ahead they saw it before we get into it
and he goes into it but okay go ahead
well no no I don't want to say it it's
okay
my friend texted me whoa Gene R.I.P Gene
Hackman okay and didn't look it up and
then I admittedly also did the same
thing I texted you guys without even
looking it up actually I texted you guys
and then I went on Twitter and I was
like this is weird nothing really what
he did so but I did it faster and with
more efficiency and with more questions
what I didn't do right is spread
misinformation right so why did that
person do it this is what he didn't even
ask why that person did it right well
how am I supposed to know that here we
go see that's what I knew about it
that's what I wanted to get into I knew
you didn't ask your friend hey
why did you say that what made you think
of that right well why would I say why
did you do that I know my friends well
we asked you why but so wait hold on
that's crazy somebody text me hey
[__] uh Hugh Jackman died I go oh wow
and then look it up it didn't happen I
the first thing I text is yo why did you
say G or uh they obviously made a
mistake and so did I oh obviously
the difference is what that you would do
what you would vet it first before
passing it on after I realized it didn't
happen I'd say what the hell made you
say oh oh I didn't even understand that
yeah that's what you're saying you found
out it was not true and then didn't tell
your friend and I knew that because I
know my friends oh I did
you were not being that clear I don't
think he understood I didn't understand
why did your friend do it uh when
somebody makes a mistake like that they
say whoa I [__] up and I I don't say
hey why did you do that oh you didn't do
it so he didn't do it he's like somebody
just unbelievable how many twists this
was like an M Night shyamaha movie
already and it's been five minutes I
have one question it keeps getting
answered different ways so annoying
though but good yeah I guarantee the
answer here's why I guarantee the answer
is abundantly clear it just hasn't been
said by him
okay go go go go go go
did you ask the person
what made you say that why did you think
that
no no
I knew that too so why did you ask him
that's my point
you don't know that he I knew it before
he said you know what I'm gonna do it
right when I woke up this morning okay
right now what okay now it's 48 hours
later I still want to know the French
litter are gonna be like what
I never did that you know this is one
we're talking about one thing
if somebody were to tell me Hugh Jackman
died and I said really then found out he
didn't the first thing I would ask that
person is what made you say that yeah
it's different then what then saying why
did you do that the same thing it's the
same thing it's the same thing it's
getting at the same thing it's like they
saw a tweet okay okay
so you do know I do know how do you know
well you told me here we go
here we go what's happening right now
they told me I mean I knew that was
coming right now they shared with me
what they saw that made them do that
for real
I honestly what is happening uh
I'm gonna show you what this tweet is I
wish I could care defend him better you
know what I mean but I can't no he's
it's indefensible yeah
this is the Tweet okay rip Gene Hackman
your life wasn't just an adventure it
was a Poseidon Adventure note to self
make sure Gene Hackman is dead before
you tweet there's also another Gene
Hackman movie besides Poseidon Adventure
very stupid joke and anyone who read it
would know that Gene Hackman's not dead
yeah I would read that and be like who's
your friend it's just I I would read
that and I go uh Gene Hackman didn't die
they yeah me too obviously only read the
first part and then thought whoa Gene
Hopkins dead you know what this is a
testament to
How likely it is
to be [__] when you hear something
third or fourth hand yeah like how easy
or rather how easy it is
to like a total untruth get into the
slipstream and everyone's like did you
know you know John Goodman died me just
me saying that right now there's gonna
be people like John Goodman die yeah
yeah and that's I guarantee you you know
what I guarantee is that this we're
recording this on Wednesday it comes out
Sunday Gene Hackman's gonna die between
Wednesday and Sunday and so John he's
going to make it even more confusing
yeah yeah yeah
um
should we even release the episode
all right yeah well Gene Hackman is
alive John Goodman is alive Wednesday
this is by when Wednesday Hugh Jackman
Gene Hackman and John Goodman are alive
it's Wednesday do you ever think about
uh how Hugh Jackman's name is almost
huge [__] no you've never thought
that it's actually not almost huge ass
it's about half the huge yeah yeah soul
yeah you're just out of that Soul it's
actually two-thirds of the way there
huge [__] instead of Hugh Jack come
in
so it's all good though it's still true
but if you drop two syllables and just
add Soul yeah huge [__] yeah yeah you
know yeah
oh I know
but oh you got too many iced coffees
yeah but they're off camera nobody can
see so you exposed me okay well I'm
happy so you've been exploded so you've
been exposed now explain
it's a really boring explanation it is
boring what the [__] how could it be
riveting there's two because who comes
in
like this with two iced coffees I didn't
come in other than a maniac one was here
because Chris ordered it for me oh kind
man and one was here because I brought
it because I had it kind you're a kind
man that's good
he's just surfing Twitter right now
oh it was Tam okay Tam I texted a huge
group chat about his death then finished
reading this tweet oh well yeah well at
least she came clean you know thanks Tim
no all right
well that's cool man thank God he's not
dead I guess I mean he is nice sent me
into a tailspin but at least she came
clean what they what what age do you
think is a good age to be like all right
life's done
way before 93 which is how old Gene
Ackman is yeah
I mean 93. I think he's 93 right he was
the oldest one out of that wave of
actors yeah from the 60s and 70s uh like
he was already in his 40s when he did
French Connection which is like right
just exploded
which was 1925
so yeah what is that yeah I mean he's 90
something if that's the case because
that was in the 70s yeah yeah yeah I S
yeah wow that's crazy man wow but what
why what do you think
I mean I think after 80 you're just like
so slow but you probably don't want to
die
so I don't know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I don't know because like after 80
people start to get really like yeah
like you know like
for sure yeah yeah it's unavoidable but
and then there's was that there was that
guy who was that guy Lee Haney that
would Lee Haney the bodybuilder no not
Lee Hayden
oh wait who's that I know who that is
look up Jack LaLanne
Jack Lalane
uh wait was he like on an infomercial or
something yeah okay there he was oh my
God look at Jacksonville Lane yeah but
he's right there he's 110.
but he would like do a hundred [__]
pull-ups he was just like the fittest
guy in the world how old was he I'm told
well he yeah he lived to be like 90 or
something I don't know Wow 85 86 didn't
even live that long you know yeah he was
96. 96 never mind yeah no but the thing
is it's that it wasn't that he lived to
be that old it was that he could do so
much [__] while he was like 90. like he
did all that working out stuff at The
Smiling pics of him dude yep oh there he
was he would do like 50 pull-ups right
there
it was crazy dude I mean I don't know 50
but no no the infomercial type in
infomercial
Jack LaLanne infomercial
there you go there you go power juicer
hair was
and to you my friends remember anything
in life is possible make it happen
goodbye everybody hi cut they go cut and
he goes I mean so rehearsed the line and
remember folks black energy oh I
remember this yeah
the Clapping
this is old school yeah yeah you put
your [__] in there with her okay man you
know stainless steel blades just a
maniac performance
slowly
[__] like that I love [__] like that
yeah yeah the rudimentary Graphics
if you don't do it who will juicing is
the easy way to help save your life
Justin is the easy way so
he wanted to be I guess all right look
this is uh go to patreon.com Lifeline
luxury to get the uh other Lifeline
luxury podcast which is just us [__]
and we're gonna get into some videos
here uh from you guys uh but Lifeline
luxury is the new podcast with us and go
on over to our patreon uh you could also
all be in Tucson I'll be in Colorado
I'll be in Nashville I'll be in Montreal
I'll be in a bunch of different places
christilia.com that's stand up that's me
doing stand up uh if you've got a
question
um go to watch lifeline.com or leave us
a message on the hotline
213-973-8095 uh go ahead oh you know
what I'm down you got something to talk
about you talk to somebody you need to
talk to somebody making a point with me
at matalia.com you got one on one it's
private you get me you get the real me
you know you get the real me all right
and everybody wants that okay book your
session and guess what we got the new
merch did you already say this no uh at
lifelinemerch.com it's sick I wear it
all the time especially the purple
hoodie cool
um all right so let's do a video huh
hi guys need some advice
um my cat has been
going next door to my neighbor's house
who has a bird sanctuary and scaring her
Birds that neighbor came up to my door
this morning she's a mid-60s you know
typical Karen and she said she opened
with us do you know millions of birds
die every year oh my God I'm very
confused
um she proceeds to then tell me that if
my cat is found on her property again
she's going to take her to the pound oh
so I guess my advice would be it's how
do you deal with parents because oh God
they're just the worst yeah thank you
bird is their birds are caged I mean
they're obviously not just no it's a
bird sanctuary I think they're not well
they're not but then they would just fly
away right no the bird sanctuary is a
place that they come Roost mcness so she
just has a house birds actually by where
I live it's just open and it's a place
where Birds okay so I understand that
but also it's our house I mean I think
it's her yard I don't think it's inside
her house well it's not in her house
because then they would it's on her
property right it's on her property of
course they can fly away but they come
back is the point okay so if they can
fly away then what's it matter with the
cat being there more but what I really
think you should do is just to like end
it say if you do that to my cat we're
gonna have such an enormous problem that
you don't want
and they can say well why are you
threatening me you can say why are you
threatening me yeah you know like I just
don't do that because we're gonna have
an enormous problem do it from the
standpoint of like concern though be
like if you do that to my cat there's
going to be a huge problem right now
there's a kind of a limited problem that
we can fix together as two neighbors as
people start out by saying do you like
limited problems like jacly Lane yeah
like an infomercial no but for real like
you don't want it to be a bigger problem
either and you know she doesn't oh God
so just be like look it's it's gonna
become such an enormous problem for you
if you do that that neither one of us
want that to happen so don't do that
just come and get me and we'll figure it
out you're like oh [__] man next time it
happens I'm a little bit worried about
this big problem that you've just
started it sucks right it sucks between
me and you it just [__] sucks you
opened up Pandora's Box now this is
rough
because I don't want I don't want this
problem and you've just kind of forced
me into it so now it's like you threaten
me no but so where do we go from here
you do it what if you did that for real
it would be amazing I mean amazing I
would also recommend that but it's hard
to pull that off you gotta be a good
actor yeah uh and I am okay but yeah say
I'm not I think if you do it before the
she does the bad thing it's way better
you're operating from she already did
past tense no she didn't get her cat and
bring to the pound no oh I I see what
you're saying yeah so it's like it's but
the problem is already created because
she said hey she threatened her no no
but you as like the bigger person before
it happens you can say let's snip this
in the butt because it's gonna become a
huge problem and I don't want that well
it's like the beginning of the scene
when the guy's like the karate masters
like being picked on by like 10 Street
Hooligans and he's like just trust me
you're going to want to walk away you
know what I mean please do do us all a
favor and just go when it comes to cash
and they slap you in the face and then
he kicks the [__] when it comes to cats
and birds I'm a karate master hey hey
well you don't need to go that walk away
much like the movie you know lady walk
away
okay but you're missing the point you're
making it about karate and I'm just
saying you can take pointers from the
movies in this instance site
what was that oh um dude I think that uh
you go you say oh your birds can fly
away right and then she says yeah all
good catch you later spin move out she
didn't move out
hey bro wait hold on let me Google Birds
they can fly we're good spin move
you're out Ace Ventura this part yeah
but it's true though man other oh dude
cats [__] well you know what dude okay
I'm Gonna Fly so we're good dude but
it's known that cats kill birds they do
yeah [__] ass birds of all the fittest
you want to raise that's not a good
argument sweetheart you want to raise
weak Birds my cat's doing you guys a
favor you get these strong birds out
there keeping them sharp yeah
like this
oh dude how about like uh um
like uh
what do you call it uh play musical
theater kids like when you're in high
school they do [__] like
when they get married what do you call
it you just describe yeah whatever they
call it that's what you call it you know
in high school and [__] when they'd be
mad they thought that was the thing to
do they'd be like
you know where did you go to high school
cats at University absolutely crazy
person high school there was a girl when
they get mad go like this yeah there was
one girl that did it she would go like
you don't want to piss me off you know
and I'll be like oh [__] man I I
actually I mean so turned on
no it felt so cringe I was like oh Jesus
I was in high school
yeah or college was it like this big and
had whiskers and a tail
okay yeah the cat it was a cat oh cat
yeah okay
uh I mean actually Google the birds fly
yeah no no uh 2.4 billion so [__]
many the United States alone outdoor
cats killer probably two wow that killed
2.4 billion Birds a year how many birds
would there be if there were no cats
Jesus Christ though he Birds everywhere
I mean that's such a good population
control thank you cats dude bring up
this article the one the woman is over
at your place complaining and say look
this is nature this is how it's
literally if it wasn't like this the
world will be overrun with birds dude
nobody wants that yeah even crazy bird
lady yeah cats are oh cats are crazy bro
because they would they will kill birds
even if they're not hungry they just
kill them they just go cats are just
straight up wild animals that can't
really kill humans so we use them as
pets like any that's not true of most
wild animals most wild animals will kill
us that's why we don't have them as pets
cats are just like small they can't
really really mess around and they can
but so but like cats do not give a [__]
they'll kill birds and like get it
almost dead and then just [__] with it
but way before like it's torturing it we
need to cancel cats cats are messed up I
mean I like cats but like they're
hardcore not me wild animals no it's the
worst cats in Musical
no I like Cats the musical no I saw it
it's bad okay I saw it too it's good so
now what when did you see it recently
when
ever it was in L.A it was at the
Pantages I went with him I saw it then
it was bad
it was bad no it wasn't dude was it bad
oh yeah
yeah
it wasn't like an amazing production and
also it's bad all right next all right
yep
Dungeons and Dragons so
um I'm a new dungeon master and the
dungeon master is the guy who who runs
all the characters uh through the game
of Dungeons and Dragons and kind of
controls what's going on yeah so this
requires me to play a lot of different
uh characters that are in the world of
Dungeons and Dragons and
um have my players interact with with
those characters so uh my my request is
that you guys would hopefully be able to
give me some advice on just voice acting
in general
um and help me be able to potentially
use my own voice to create as many
unique characters
um as possible and would love to hear
your guys's feedback on that
um second off uh this is a super nerdy
thing so if you guys could give me
advice on how to not feel so
self-conscious about my wife
um hearing me in the Next Room uh that
would be great oh my God that might be
my favorite come here pretty you know
come in here foreign
[Music]
okay but
I mean that might be my favorite
submission yeah ever because I started
out I was like damn what all right so
and then by the end I was like oh damn
this is good so complicated yeah so
dungeon master is what he's saying right
yeah so can you YouTube like Dungeons
and Dragons dungeon master like he's
talking about doing different voices for
the characters you narrating the game as
dungeon master okay and you're like in
charge of tips for Dungeon Masters holy
[__] but I've never heard of voices
being done I guess when you're in the
role of another character he wants to
embody them you know yeah and uh that's
cool to be that committed but like
tips on how to use your voice that is
not something I can uh help you with
uh but you know you're uh
you're the man of many voices you know I
got like six voices here all right well
what are they and how do you do them so
you got to be like I well I don't know a
dick about Dungeons and Dragons you just
[__] it's like we need a fantasy
thing though but you it's like if you
read a book right yeah you'd read most
of it as action and narration be the
quotes and then the horned devil says
yeah yeah exactly well you know hello
good good good good that's one where is
the princess here's the thing though you
gotta commit yeah yeah right that's
really good I hope it doesn't find me
good job High voices for girls
uh the more evil the person is the lower
so here's the tip that's true if you get
to a guy who you think is pretty evil
don't use your lowest register there
might be somebody more Evil later yeah
that's good right yeah but then when
they're really evil
yeah that's that's right honestly we
gotta cut I gotta go to the bathroom and
I can't and I can't wait okay
okay
all right we're back and we're back yeah
you gotta commit to it though you got to
commit to it otherwise it's like you'll
it's so the kind of thing that if you
don't commit property all the time it's
like it's gonna seem like insecure or
like you that you suck at it like
don't bother doing any voices unless
you're going to commit to it 100 that's
what that's that's what I'll say the
other thing I'll say is dude here's the
thing
it's hard to find something for anyone
during their life that they love so if
you love to play Dungeons and Dragons
don't feel like whatever like nerd the
nerd label is gonna be on that game
forever it won't matter like but just
embrace it and say like who like who
really cares a nerd nerds are popular
now anyway like who cares dude yeah dude
there's a lot of nerds yeah and uh find
your nerd friends yeah just be a nerd
with like no
no shame
there's no shame in it even if what's in
it is Dungeons and Dragons right dungeon
master of dungeons I saw a little bit of
that movie that came out with Chris Pine
you know
it's not bad oh wow okay is this the
movie critics Corner session of the show
yeah I guess so really really animated
welcome and really delved it you really
delved into your opinion welcome to
movie corner
okay yeah I just feel uh yeah I don't
yeah your wife already you already she
married you married her you're good bro
you got the chick well he's obviously
understandably con I mean it's a valid
concern just because they're married
doesn't it's not like 1910 she can she
can leave the marriage yeah but she's
not gonna do that because you're gonna
be like yo I like Dungeons and Dragons
when she says something about it be like
park it I like Dungeons and Dragons or
don't be mean and say park it or just be
like be like yeah I like it yeah it's
really fun or be like this yes I love it
my pretty yeah or that like I said there
you go whatever it is you're doing you
got to commit to it and if that's the
lane you choose to go down then do that
too but yeah dude you gotta look it just
is what it is you love it oh and people
love it it's not it's a thing to love
just be one of the people who loves this
game yeah who cares all right next one
this is about like I eat something spicy
dude what's up so my best friend's video
on this because she's a legend
quick question that I feel like most
people are thinking but haven't wanted
to ask and it's really been driving me
crazy I love Lifeline I love watching it
thank you and I'm a big fan and
sometimes it's okay you know to say life
rips and as we all do
but I've noticed why am I getting
teary-eyed right now
I've noticed when people send in videos
they like
you know when you watch someone so much
you take On Their Manners yeah yeah
and so many people have done that with
you and I just need to know you Chris no
and sometimes Matt I need to know does
that bother you
or am I a bad person for being bothered
by people I understand people getting
bothered by that things or is it like
cool because
because yeah I do know
the revolution of talking like you but
no us dude let me be clear sure but we
created that it's not just me okay it
just it got puddled on my podcast
obviously yeah so
um
uh yeah I I I does it bother me oh a lot
of if it's bad a lot of times people do
it bad then it's like but also it's
it doesn't bother me because it makes
them happy and I love making people
happy and when they do it if they think
they're funny doing it which sometimes
they are sometimes they aren't but like
I I have heard people fans say that
about other fans uh and is it it's it's
only bad if it's bad if it's but isn't
it all
maybe I misunderstanding what's
happening but isn't it all in honor of
being a fan of yes yes I I mean because
what she's saying she's if she's talking
about fans and I think that's probably
what it is I for me it's an experience
of people who know me yeah
will come on to the way that but here's
what it is it's not just that like it's
not that like the way of talking that
either one of us does is like people
want to like necessarily do it it's just
that I have come to believe that some
people talk in very specific ways yeah
and those people tend to be like one or
two per group right and people in that
group if they're gonna end up talking
like anybody they're gonna end up
talking like the one who's got a really
specific Strong Style yeah and and you
know look I'm very influential and it's
just you know but I do understand that
and that's like when I hear people say
like you know other comedian friends of
mine that do this like Callan we sounded
like sometimes we're like oh he's trying
to bite you it's like dude no we're
friends like like Jerry Seinfeld and and
what's and uh Larry David they sound
alike a lot okay oh only one's more you
know swear wordy and one's not but um
yeah uh you know I you know I don't know
that's just like I think people talk
like I think what you're describing with
you and your fans is just like an
expansion of what naturally happens in
circles and groups yeah yeah this is
just happens to be a big group where the
people don't necessarily know each other
yeah so I think it's probably more
pronounced when somebody speaks like you
because it's like you don't have a right
or whatever I also think that when
they're sending in a video they're like
I want to do this that 100 so it comes
across a little more inauthentic than
you would in a friend group but if you
were just hanging out with this person I
don't think they'd be doing it all the
time you know oh what I was gonna say is
when people call in with videos they
they do it because they think it not
only that you'll like it yeah as like uh
oh compliment yeah but like I think that
they also want to it's a it's a signal
that they are aware of you and are a fan
of yours yeah yeah it's not just them
trying to be like funny like you
yeah if you look at it that way it's
less uh it's like a way of commit uh
communicating information yeah but I do
I you know I understand there's there's
there's
uh people that want to be a part of you
know the log cabin and [__] and uh they
want to prove it that they want to be
part of the log cabin and
um you know a politician Carpenters we
have Carpenters we have Chris Delia we
have gardeners Log Cabin we have uh uh
people that are in responsible for
zoning wow and uh we will increase
expenses when it comes to uh certain
things of of that nature so thank you uh
very much
um and it will happen I I hear you but
it will happen
um just give it some time thank you very
much because
excuse me
wow we're gonna go the whole rest of the
hour you know
all right cool so they think that it'll
help them get on the show really and it
doesn't so oh wow wow
wow wow doesn't
let me tell you one thing it doesn't
gonna fight
um but yeah there's there's different
levels of fans and I appreciate them all
and we appreciate them all politicians
uh really there's nothing nothing wrong
about it thank you very much well
nothing wrong about it you know uh what
if there was a position that at the end
of every speech he said and there's
nothing wrong with any of the things I
said
thank you very much excuse me
I mean coming no that's I know what you
were trying to do okay who comes up but
you went like this
I mean I don't know all right next one
right next one
hey y'all so I am currently 36 weeks
pregnant wow and my husband and I aren't
finding out the gender of her baby so I
Slide the baby out and so with that we
have to have at least one boy name and
one girl name picked out when we go to
the hospital or just like Kelly
um with that picking a name has been all
difficult and I was wondering if y'all
think that there is any difference
between naming a dog and naming a human
yeah because there's some names
sound a little too funky that I don't
think should be put on a human
but then it would be really cool to have
that kind of name like a funky name but
I don't want them to be made fun of and
say like
you know have some weird [__] name
yeah so they all think that there is any
difference between human names and dog
names
Fido and spot you know I I you know like
meatball you know you don't go name a
child meatball unless you're really
famous you know what I mean there is
Meatloaf so like yeah but he came into
meatloaf there's parents weren't like
and and good night to little meatloaf
you know what I mean he came into my man
was like that's a meatloaf guy
um yeah I I I think that uh you there
are I don't you know it's fine to name
your dog a human name I think like that
that way
of course is fine but if you're asking
if it's okay to name people with Butters
things that people name dogs I think the
answer is absolutely no no because
here's the thing if you want a funky
name guess what else you can use what a
funky right right right right right
right right like what like Firestorm
like well no that's more just the now
that's a Transformer it's a noun oh oh
it's a neighbor Transformer yeah I guess
then Firestorm or like uh
Blaze that's funky Blaze that's a
terrible name but yeah I mean Blaze is
sick dude Blaze is rad it's also spelled
b-l-a-i-s-e if you oh if you want but if
you want to get funky you see
b-l-a-z-z-z oh God blahs you know Blaze
Blaze hey I'm Bloss blasdalia my name is
Blas yeah are you supposed to be Blaze
but they put three C's at the end look
like it just fell asleep dude for real
name your kid blauze but threes and then
forever play him this clip so that if
it's a boy named Blas if it's a girl
named blasa Blas is the worst name I get
blaza blasa dude yeah yeah
um remember that song
blase blase who made yeah songs about
her songs
um yeah dude don't name your son spot or
Fido name your kid Blas don't he or she
will always have this to look back on as
such a warm memory of how War memory
selected your video of millions and
millions of videos and now we get to
name you go with God
we love you I think you should wait till
this uh baby comes out look at the baby
and then solidify the name
like I we wanted to name him Calvin and
then he came out and we were like yes
okay Calvin yes Mike that makes sense
with William he came out first we had a
few names in mind and we were like ah
the day like a day went by and we're
like I think he's a William you know
you got to let it speak to you you gotta
let the baby speak to you you know or
you can do like hey Kelly Morgan we
don't know if it's a boy or girl he
comes out she comes out it's gonna be
that name right Kelly Morgan whatever
you wanna Morgan what other name Kelly
Morgan name your child Kelly Morgan
thanks what other names are there Kelly
what do you mean that are oh oh geez uh
Kelly Morgan Kelly and Morgan
uh Robin Robin Robin Robin Batman
Chris Tina Christina no Chris or
Christina right yeah but Christina for
men too Christina is kind of a weird
name it makes me think of like it was
just a guy's name and then they just
changed it to a girl's name I don't like
that I like that the most really yeah
like Bruce Bruce Ella well no not all of
them but the ones that exist are like
George and Georgia or Georgia and Jordan
Georgina those are cool names you know
hey my name is hi my name is Bruce Ella
you know wow
um most the most annoying voice
that you just did when you were brucella
that is the single most hi my name is
Bruce Ella it's like why I don't know
it's just like encompasses all men all
Annoying male and female yeah I'm a good
one okay well that's not what I was
saying okay let's do the next one blast
name of blast so blind I have a question
blind
I got invited to it
could have started the video more blind
so I have a question
and advice how come I can't see I got
invited to a French bachelor party and
obviously definitely a good friend
but
I'm running out of vacation days I've
already spent a bunch of money this year
I'm going to a New York Giants game in
Arizona and just an overall expensive
year right
and his bachelor party is in September
I don't want to go oh there you go it's
gonna be another 1500 weekend yeah it's
crazy and I've ran out of vacation days
is it like a dick to not go or is it
more dick to make up an excuse why I
can't go or do I just be honest and say
listen man I'm gonna have to sit this
one out
just want to know what you guys think
love what you do and let's see some
advice thanks guys perfect use of this a
dick without being it being cringy
okay yeah I'm talking about reference to
the earlier questions yeah reference to
the earlier question just came out just
did it is this a dick or is it nuts a
dick all right well here's here's the
deal
and I mean this from the bottom of my
heart and I want everybody to listen to
this piece of advice because it applies
to so many people so many different
times I'm trans and it's okay he's
asking if it's okay to not essentially
he's asking if it's okay to not do
something right and here's the answer
for every question like that okay yes it
is completely okay to not do the thing
whatever that is yeah and this guy yeah
size case it's a bachelor party guess
what he doesn't want to go he doesn't go
yeah and everything
everything for everyone yeah right vote
for Matt okay the meters on the screen
dude I I couldn't agree more man you
know you don't need to go to Bachelor
parties you don't need to go to weddings
you don't need to go to anything
especially if it costs [__] racks you
know what I mean it doesn't make a
difference for me but I get it dude
fifteen hundred dollars are racks you
know that's a rack and a half you know
what I mean and it's too much money dude
absolutely so disrespectful to ask your
friend to come to the bachelor party to
get some freaking racks you know wow you
know to spend rocks I spent rocks
I know you're going to I know you're
going to uh the Giants and New York game
and spend a lot of money but you know
hey by the way could you spin a rock and
a half just because I want to go get
hitched and I want to [__] play poker
somewhere dude no this is why don't go
that's why I didn't want to get into the
specifics yeah dude there's poker and
all that stuff at a bachelor party but
it applies to anything yeah dude stop
throwing the stuff because here's the
thing even if the person asking you yeah
to do it even if they don't like it
guess what they respect it because they
wish they could do what you just did in
their own Life Time and Time and Time
and Time and Time Again
they respect it
okay
where's the baby give me a baby to kill
the polls dude I feel like that is uh
great advice tell them do not make an
excuse be like Yo dude I'm already
spending that's an excuse but that's an
experience
and then it literally said don't make an
excuse and then gave said say an excuse
no no I I meant don't make something up
don't be like oh don't lie don't lie
sorry yeah yeah right correct yeah but
be like yo you know I I don't I can't go
I don't have the money and also it's
just not gonna be my thing in September
is a rough time for me to do it just
[__] can't go yeah can't go
text back or on the email chain reply
all can't go I mean then you're a dick
see then if you do it like that you
actually are a dick but just simply
saying the actual truth yeah not only
will feel good and you won't feel like
you're lying which is obviously great
but you will be respected for it all
thank you very much at the I'll see you
at the polls reply all on the computer
do entrepreneur on phone can't go in
parentheses sniff send no can't go in
parentheses don't wanna yeah
all right well that's the advice for the
ages we should just close shop the
show's over that's enough
is it's just I don't you know even
dinners sometimes it's like asking your
friends to go to dinners where it's
gonna be like [__] 600 it's like
don't do that dude or pay for it I mean
totally pay for it like yeah yeah that
makes a difference for me but it's like
rocks you know just
wanted to say racks again no but it's
fine
before I got a diving board on my
pockets right but it doesn't matter dude
because my pockets but if you feel so
uncomfortable to have the diving board
in your pocket
just always in pain Little People
bouncing off that diving board going
into the thing like DuckTales all right
Arnold
all right next one dude also bachelor
party sucker what's up Chris what's up
Matt what about this podcast on the tube
right here used to think it was
congratulations but uh the brotherly
banter just puts this one over the edge
loving it um so my dilemma here I just
got back from an Italy trip this trip
was planned about five months ago with
one of my best friends who's a girl
um and two of my other best friends a
couple and we played it five months ago
and then the last leg of the trip
um the friend and I the girl we were
staying in the same bedroom right
um fast forward to now I've been seeing
a very special girl for about three
months and
um I had told her that we were staying
in separate rooms the whole time uh last
night of the trip literally the night
before I came back
um nothing all the whole time I was gone
just excited to see each other
um the girl in my bed sneezes and the
girl hears it while we're on the phone
and she goes who was that and I go oh it
was me
terrible call bad decision
um really messed that one up obviously
uh but I said it was me we kind of blew
it over I wake up in the morning to a
text uh breaking up with me basically uh
we've been going back and forth
um she keeps saying she needs space then
she ends it again and I'm just wondering
what I can do there nothing happened
with me and the girl nothing's ever
happened with me and that girl
um I don't know how to explain to her I
don't know if I've just completely lost
trust
um she's a super special girl girl in my
dreams really so um if you guys got any
advice for me to
um help the situation get her back
smooth it over did I just blow it uh let
me know appreciate you guys thanks again
for all the advice and keep it up with
the Pod don't hang out with allergic
[__]
okay so moving on to mine
um it was a joke I think so that it was
a joke
I don't even say that word I here's this
way man but it was wow okay it was a
joke everybody we know she wasn't
allergic um but also what happened what
he was talking to her and the chick and
then the girl stays in the background
yeah and it was a chick that he wasn't
hooking up with
what the [__] do you do on this show I a
little bit stopped paying attention why
it's an hour dude it's a [__] hour
you can pay attention for like the 12
minutes total of the video what happened
was
ah I [__] [__] I checked out for
about five seconds and it was during a
very important part of the video and I
was lost
I got the rest of it but it didn't all
right well he's good friends with this
girl yeah oh been friends with her for a
really long time uh they never dated or
anything they never told the late the
new girl that he was gonna go with the
girl he did but he specifically didn't
say we were going to be sleeping in the
same bed because he I don't know I guess
he knew she I don't know the same thing
oh yeah okay so
of course it did
is it better now yes
okay so here's the thing that's pretty
weird you I know what happened now are
dumb yeah that was a dumb for doing that
right but I don't
here's the thing the problem is is that
you didn't tell her in the first place
you can't say well why don't you trust
me because you broke the trust so now
you're kind of in you're gonna have to
be playing defense and you're kind of
[__] already but I think that
look if she just outright doesn't
believe you doesn't want to talk to you
yeah and that's that you got to kiss a
goodbye you can't you can't do anything
about it for you you got to say bye but
if she's just like
if she's willing to talk to the girl who
sneezed uh anyone else who might attest
to your actual relationship
and hear it out then you know maybe
it'll be some kind of patching up some
sort of understanding it's the girl your
dreams you want to try to obviously make
it work but that's not always possible
and when it's not possible you have to
let it go let's not let's not
negate
how annoying it is that that girl
sneezed
you know what I'm talking about I get it
what he did was wrong but oh my [__]
god do the thing where you do like this
so in all of this experience dramatic
the the woman who sneezed I'm not mad at
her but come on dude but what about the
guys you [__] lied and messed up the
situation for himself in the first he
was wrong but also like this yeah yeah
yeah I chew
you couldn't uh what no it's me I put
the phone away and I just let me ask
everybody's High pictures ever been a
time where you couldn't not sneeze in
your life no
are you you're lying you know that's
cool but you're lying it's my body is it
bodysuit I'm never here you are lying
I've never heard more than once I've
never hiccuped more than once that
wasn't my question even a little bit how
the [__] could you answer with that I
mean Donald Trump you know
I do not do what I don't want to do with
my body okay okay what do you mean if I
don't want to see these I won't sneeze
so what if somebody
took a big big yes sharp knife yep cut
you like this what would happen I would
bleed because you wanted to uh no that's
different okay well then continue to
explain cause and effect you can't stop
that but you can stop sneezing because
that's my body I go like this that
really is just a different kind of cause
and effect their nose hairs got tickled
and there's there she blows dude like
this HMS pinafore but I've never heard
more than once I've never taken more
than once I don't give a [__] I bet you
do that how many times you've hiccups it
is interesting that I've done that I'm
talking about that though what about the
sneeze
but what I'm saying is if I go I go like
this
I think about how it's my body okay
Krishna murti in the meantime twice
don't know who that is but that's so
[__] dorky you said that Christian
MRT Krishna murti okay
our clothing designer anybody who knows
anything a clothing designer outside of
their own little [__]
wool cuffs with big cuffs and gold like
swirlies not exactly Christian amarti
not exactly all right
um so it is annoying and that person who
sneezed needs to be held accountable a
little ah you idiot dude so sneezed huh
I've never wanted to just Pummel you
maybe in my life I want to pumble you
right now how wrong you are to focus it
on that no it's just so simple it's
annoying that he was he was wrong I'm
not saying he was wrong what I do is I
look at you're not saying you're wrong I
say he was wrong but I look at the
different parts and the different angles
okay I look at the different things
every that person sneeze that's very
annoying as [__] it is annoying as [__]
that that person sneeze you can't fight
me on that annoying I mean unfortunate I
would I would I would use the word
unfortunately would you not be annoyed
you would be annoyed you wouldn't find
yourself in that situation I would be an
annoyed about this situation that I put
myself in yeah in the moment in like the
very that exactly what I want to know is
is that guy like hey don't say anything
I'm gonna be talking about the [__]
thing you know that's what I mean once
you lie you got to be a liar that's bad
yeah the reason you don't lie is because
you gotta be a liar you can't just lie
once you got to keep lying yay Matt wait
you're saying lie what you're saying lie
keep lying no no no no oh yeah yay Delia
says lie yeah
um uh all right no yeah you just you you
put yourself in a hole so if she's just
gone you gotta let it go and that's it
don't pester don't annoy you you
triggered some trigger that it was not
okay with her and that's fair and you
gotta let her remember her mom when she
was younger died by his knees all you
can do is learn the lesson of don't lie
about little [__] that you're actually
being faithful about anyway yeah I know
really the worst [__] it wasn't even
a necessary lie I know if you're not
doing the horizontal Mamba with that
with that other woman why are you lying
about it why are you lying yeah you just
want her to like you want her to be okay
and I get it yeah I get it too and I get
it get it too but not everybody
I know everybody can't have everything
that they want to admit that you
yourself are not every single thing that
a person wants yeah that's exactly right
and I get it more than that
so next one yeah okay
[__] we've had him so yeah what's up
Matt and Chris return caller here I was
inspired by The Piano guy from Northern
California with a veneer teeth who had
questions about hair my quick advice is
to him hey dude grow your hair out you
don't have to color it your hair looks
great you just make it longer oh yeah
and then maybe people will call you Liu
Kang for the rest of your life thanks a
lot anyway I have an update about my
whole situation with Crossroads the
thrift store right you can take my fear
of God and Kanye West related related
stuff because of him not being a nice
guy yeah
um that day I'd gotten so frustrated I
did a bunch of research on the web found
Crossroads corporate headquarters found
some contacts on LinkedIn contacted a
lady she ended up calling me we had a
fairly long conversation about morals
and values in society Etc and um she
took some sort of
managerial actions
um on the employees that I interfaced
with at the location that I went to so
it overall was just a weird thing it was
a weird feeling and I mean I don't I
hope that person like didn't lose their
job or anything yeah
and I don't want to be in trouble for
yeah whatever it is that Connie is up to
really quick before I go I did have a
quick question about something that I
could use some advices on do you guys
ever find yourself
throughout the day measuring everything
like the the the time that it takes to
do stuff I find myself doing that and my
therapist says it's a form of anxiety
assuredly it is but it's one of those
things I'm just like how do I not do
that how do I just relax and say it
might take me an hour to get here it
might take me two hours to get here
um it might take me two minutes to brush
my teeth it might take me 30 seconds but
who cares you know how do I just live my
life that's it really before I go though
sorry I lied Matt thank you for making
me that little birthday video my sister
convinced you last year it was
absolutely hilarious she made me a whole
compilation and you were the cherry on
top so anyways guys thank you so much
love what you do curious to hear your
feedback that's amazing so yeah uh this
guy overthinks a lot of [__] clearly
yeah because that was one of his
questions
how do I stop overthinking and just
enjoy yeah but but even the thing that
where he had to call the person and they
talked a long time here's the thing that
you didn't even realize he was snitching
but he was just talking too much but
here's what happens when you ask too
many questions you get somebody else in
trouble
yeah get somebody else in trouble you
ask too many questions that's true just
let it go he can't let stuff go as his
problem you gotta let stuff go I know
guys like that you gotta let stuff go
and let it you know like toilet paper
you wipe your ass with it that it's got
[__] all over it so instead of holding
on to it guess what you do you flush it
down the toilet eat it oh that's what we
should do with experiences right we have
good and bad experiences but when we
have a bad one yeah
it was a bad one that I don't want to
think about anymore guess what right
it's got [__] on it where's the toilet
first analogy put it in the toilet bowl
flush it hey where'd the memory go it's
gone uh
we got only happy ones oh I don't know
who wants only happy memories and
experiences me too what you do is yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah and what you do is you
take it like it's a piece of toilet
paper that has [__] on it and just like
a bad experience you get [__] all over
it you don't want to hold on to it
because it's got [__] on it and it's
terrible and you put it in the toilet
when you're done with it and guess what
you do you flush it and it goes bye
it goes bye bye oh no poopy go bye-bye
oh God poopy experience and go bang bang
this dude yeah I think that honestly you
think too much relax breathe [__]
don't even have a watch that watch is
one of the things I noticed take that
watch throw it out the [__] window
put up your ass wow cut your hair
do all sorts of stuff that doesn't
matter I'm gonna be in Tucson coming up
chrisley.com wow oh you got it just
literally you know if you're in Colorado
you can come see me krista.com but dude
you just gotta go do
oh my God
just relax dude
like
easier said than done
you have some in my throat yeah no you
do yeah okay uh I think that you know
I just what I think is that
whatever man life's Just Happening
[__] chill out no man I mean it like
the guy needs to chill out dude yeah
like you're clearly a good dude and you
mean well but like you might have gotten
somebody fired you're a good dude if you
got someone fired that sucks dude and
you're a snitch but you didn't mean to
you're right but like that that's
something to be careful of but if you
don't let your mind set a little bit
you're gonna get somebody you don't want
to be an accidental snitch yeah dude
that's oh whoops oh he got fired oh no
yeah
I hate this term from when to when I
hate this term but you accidentally were
a Karen that's what that is yeah you
know yeah it's an accidental nobody
wants to be a Karen so that should be
enough reason to tone it down but it's
okay though
ain't a mistake you're still young yeah
yeah you're gonna be a [__]
accidental snitch again I like
accidental snitch over or Karen because
he didn't mean to yeah he didn't mean to
uh well Karen knows what she's doing
kind of you know accidental Karen
all right that's why I said accidental
Karen man I didn't say he was a Karen
okay I also don't use that term I take
all of that back I don't say Karen okay
well you say it's an accidental snitch
then I don't a
sit I don't say ass uh all right cool
tour tickets chrisley.com also sign up
for our patreon patreon.com Lifeline
luxury we get episodes coming out we're
popping them out uh that brother banter
left on luxury go over there it's just
five bucks uh multiple episodes a month
that are not for free only for a
patronic uh uh people uh watch Life
on.com is how you go send in a video
call the hotline or get one-on-one
sessions advice sessions with Matt
matalia.com and the lifelinemerches at
lifelinemerch.com leave a comment dude
rate my hair
rate is here let him know it's not a 10.
[Music]